Let's understand as we are sitting here that we are not an island.
We are part of the world and there are rules.
There are rules that have been established on this issues of migration.
The United Nations established the International Office on migrations
with rules. The United Nations High Commissioner for refugee
came with a convention in 1951
with 46 articles that governs all distance.
The Organisation of African Unit,
which is now AAU
came with rules about refugee and asylum seekers in 1969.
So we are not working in the vacuum.
I want to respond to foonzi.
You know, small knowledge kills at times,
especially if you expose it in front of people.
Number one, he is talking about something which is happening,
say is proposed by Action s a,
the critical skills list. We've already reviewed it three times.
We're not, we are not waiting for four years is Sammy.
We are not talking about coming to do.
We are already reviewing it.
So that is our distinct, please subtract it.
The, the problem.
Then he said there's no problem with the law.
I'll refer him tonight, go and read a judgement done by Kameron,
Judge Kameron in the cautional court,
which is unanimous judgement
who traverses the minister of Home Affairs and will read there
what is wrong with the laws.
I can even refer to chapters which I mean,
what do you call sections,
which was, which must read like section 10 because
don't shout Don't shout. I'm giving him facts.
I'm actually educating him.
There he is mentioning, yes,
there, Judge Cameron
is mentioning the contradiction between the Refugee Act
passed in 1998 and the Immigration Act passed in 2,002.
In the White Paper, we are showing
that the Citizenship Act is actually a replica of the 1949 act,
which you don't want, which was passed during the union.
So there is everything wrong with the act.
Your leader was misleading you.